We need to shift the graph down by 10,000, or in other words, the new graph will
be 10,000 lower than the old graph. This is because Grant's profit, the p
values, are all the vertical values on the graph will be each 10,000 lower than
they were in the old graph. Let's take a look at this for a second. Here are the
graphs for our old equation, the one in red. And our new equation, the one in
blue. And we can see that the blue graph is shifted just below the red one. It's
shifted down by 10,000. So the p coordinate of every single point along the blue
curve is 10.000 lower. And the p coordinate of the point with the same c
coordinate on the red curve. So it looks like changing the constants as final
terms out here can shift the graph in vertical direction and we have a parabola.
That's pretty interesting.